احتقان متواصل في شمال كوسوفو بعد
انتخابات بلديه شهدت تراجع عن قياسيا في
المشاركه تلاهو تصاعد في الجدل واعمال
العنف المحتجون ذوي الاصول الصربيه يرفضون
تمكين رؤساء البلديات الجدد من مهام عملهم
ويحاصرون مقر البلديات منذ اكثر من اسبوع
ضغطا باتجاه اعاده الانتخابات التي تتهمهم
حكومه كوسوفو بمقاطعتها في مناطقهم ما ادى
لضاله نسب المشاركه وتتهم كوسوفو حكومه
صربيا بتغذيه التوتر ووصف رئيس الوزراء
الكوسوفي البينكورتي في حديث للجزيره
الرئيس الصربي بالمستبد مؤكدا الوقوف في
وجهه بحزم
اعتقد اننا يجب ان نقف معا وبحزم في وجه
المستبدين من امثال رئيس الجاره الشماليه
لكوسوفو صربيا بدلا من محاوله استرضناهم
اكد كرتي للجزيره عدم سحب قوات شرطه
كوسوفو من محيط مقر البلديات قبل مغادره
من وصفها بالمليشيات الفاشيه العنيفه لكنه
سبق وابدى بعض المرونه قبل يومين حين لوح
على تويتر مساء الخميس باجراء انتخابات
جديده في تلك البلديات الشماليه يتخوف
رئيس الوزراء الكوسوفي كما بدا في
تصريحاته للجزيره من تخاذل واشنطن والغرب
عن دعمه سعيا لاجتذاب صربيا بعيدا عن
التحالف مع روسيا وحذر في هذا الاطار من
دفع بلاده ما اعتبره ثمنا لدى مقرطه صربيا
وصربيا في الوقت نفسه تشهد مظاهرات حاشده
في بلغراد العاصمه ترفع العلم الروسي
وتعلن دعم الصرب شمال كوسوفو ويتحدث
الرئيس الصربي الكزاندر فوتشيتش معتبرا من
عدم المصلحه الدخول في مواجهه مع حلف
الناتو داعيا في نفس الوقت لدعم صرب
كوسوفو ومرجحا اتضاح الامور بعد زياره
المبعوثين الامريكي والاوروبي الى كوسوفو
صربيا خطوره التوتر في شمال كوسوفو لا
تنبع فقط من استحضار حرب عام 98 وتس القرن
الماضي والتي قضى فيها اكثر من عشره الاف
انسان وشرد مليون اخرون لكن ايضا
لحساسيتها كنقطه احتكاك غربيه قد تفرضها
لاستقطابات مع احد حلفاء موسكو